right why don't we move ahead with our
other two speakers the next speaker will
be frank Pasquale he is a Yale graduate
among other places he's graduated from
which shall not be named because they're
the competition he's on the faculty well
all right Oxford and Harvard okay are we
okay yeah and he's currently on the
faculty of seton hall he writes articles
he blogs he speaks at many conferences
he's quoted in the media he's testified
before various government agencies
including the House Judiciary Committee
on issues raised by Google which is one
of the main credentials it brings him to
this particular panel he will be
followed by Brewster Kahle whom I think
many of us know and admire co-founder of
the Internet Archive he's been working
to provide universal access to all
knowledge for more than 25 years all of
these gentlemen have got BIOS and
incredible credentials up on the
internet so you can read more about each
of them Frank thank you very much ham
and thank you for just a wonderful
conference to the lis p I know that
there's probably be a lot of skepticism
and seeing my talk title today because
by and large we tend to think of the
American health industry as the sort of
sclerotic lumbering bumbling terrible
industry we tend to think of Silicon
Valley and Google as the pride of
America's innovation but my argument
today is essentially going to try to get
us to see or to try to convince you that
essentially there's a real similarity
between private health insurers and
Google and the way I'm going to draw
that similarity is to say that there is
a recognition in money market economies
that we are going to have middlemen
between those who can provide
information and those who need the
information okay and from the 1930s the
1960s private insurers became those
middlemen in the united states that are
very important but we realize in the
1960s that essentially they did not have
an interest in serving many parts of the
market and so in the 60s we had a public
option like medicare and medicaid
develop and my same argument will be
that in terms of digitized books
the intermediary is going to be Google
we're going to we've got to prepare for
that there may be other entrance but
I've made many arguments that is a lot
of reasons to doubt those entrance or to
doubt that they'll be very important and
so my fundamental argument today is that
just as the access cost and quality
trade-offs that our hallmark of the
health literature have guided our
treatment of middleman there of insurers
who stand between patients and doctors
that those same access costs and quality
trade-offs are going to become
incredibly important as we look at the
role that Google play's and essentially
rationing knowledge considering who gets
access to what knowledge magic air
rations access to health google books is
going to ration access to digitize
information so to begun the parallel I'd
like to think about Google as a
middleman responding to failures it
first responds to a market failure there
were too many publishers they couldn't
get together to make universal access to
their books online to digitize all the
books but there is also what's even vide
in a phone call is a public failure the
public failure is that essentially our
Congress rather than making a digital
deposit requirement that would
essentially allow the Library of
Congress to have a similar
infrastructure to that which Google is
put together fail to put that in if you
want the full sad story of that you can
look at Jessica Lippman's work and the
political economy of copyright
legislation in the book digital
Copyright it's a brilliant book but in
any case we've had this failures and
Google who's essentially imposed order
in this market much as Steve Jobs an
apple has imposed order in the there too
for chaotic music market now these can
be a really good assertion of order
right we have the ideal of but let's
start with a good insurer okay the model
of managed care all the way back to
nineteen seventy-two and it was sort of
pushed by the next administration that
into the late 90s when it really did
have some success in holding down health
costs was that they would dry of
providers absorbent costs down and they
would tear coverage so the best
treatments would get the best coverage
and the worst would get less
reimbursement and they would essentially
evaluate providers and help options and
drug formularies okay and they do that
online now you can even see doctor
rating sites where certain doctors get
five happy faces from the insurer hey
they're really effective and then some
sites where they only get one happy face
they're zena's not being effective hey
and they were supposed to reward quality
this is a big function this is the
market function of insurers the good
things that they do Google can make a
claim to do exactly parallel things with
the market for information they can
claim that they drive publishers costs
down and that just as insurers help us
sort through the bad and the good
doctors they help us sort through the
good and the bad books and results
what's relevant to us and what is not
they reward quality so what's not to
like well there's a few questions I have
about this service okay one thing is
what about tiered access imagine that
harvard gets everything yell gets almost
everything i want to really disturb our
audience here and the schools that can
only pay a hundred thousand dollars get
disabled version okay now you may say oh
that's not going to happen they're good
they're not evil but i think if you look
at the history of access to digitize
resources and especially my experience
as the chairman of the library and
Technology Committee of seen Hall Law
School I found ourselves being quite
often squeezed by digital providers of
information prices were always going up
we were had to cut away certain parts of
our budget to deal with those prices
also this is something I've written a
lot about in the context of search
engine rankings but I think it applies
off for suree in the book context is why
don't they just start manually changing
the rankings of books you know what if
they down rank books to criticize
upright books of business partners it's
a possibility what if the eliminate
books from its index well I will give
the settlement credit for dealing with
that if they eliminate a book from an
index they have to tell the registry
about it but we should also think that
tiering and serve the arrangement of a
book and book results if they bury it as
the 400th results see look for a certain
query and it's just buried in the
results that's tantamount to getting rid
of it there's no real provision for
dealing with that current law is not
going to help okay current law in
general I mean I think will not help
much and here are my reason for
skepticism the first thing is that when
people tried to question how Google
orders information and presents results
they run into in several cases the First
Amendment hey someone sued google for
having unfairly they said ranking their
site way lower than it should have been
Google put forward this first moment
arguing instead we're like a newspaper
if the government stepped in and tried
to change or to regulate our results
that would be like the government time
newspapers know what to do doing what to
tell what to do Miami Herald versa
torneo says can't do that okay very
powerful personal an argument i've
argued that should be cut back but
there's a good argument that it will be
sort of a Lochner zation of cyberspace
the first month will prevent any messing
with the results trade secrecy is the
other half's of this coin the other side
of this coin if you were to go in and
say why did my book not come up first or
why did my book come up you know in a
certain order that doesn't seem fair
they would say well if we told you that
we'd give away the trade secrets of the
company and if we did that that would
destroy its value we can't do it hey
lots of litigation against google has
sort of been hampered by that sort of
trade secrecy it happens in many areas
in terms of antitrust there is amazing
work now being done by James grimmelman
and some folks here some folks in New
York law school to try to deal with
potential antitrust problems in the
settlement I don't have time to get into
them I will say that they are doing just
just fantastic work and Pam Samuelson
has also organized some things there and
open content alliance if it gets into
the settlement that'll be great and
James grauman's work will be you know
the work on how to fix the settlement
will be a real blessing there but in
general when you think about I trust
it's a very slow way to resolve things I
know a lot of big law firms refer to
antitrust cases is almost annuities to
the firm you know they are there the
gift that keeps on giving because if you
can't get per se illegality or a quick
look you're going to go through a rule
of Reason decision that could take years
and years and years look at the
microsoft example in others so then I
think these these sort of approaches may
not help but I think there's a flip side
antitrust which is proactive government
regulation which could help where do I
draw examples from there well let's
think again about the temptations of
middlemen okay I've gone over the things
on the right about temptations for
Google in the registry for example
Robert Darton has this wonderful phrase
and last week's on the media where he
talked about cocaine pricing he worried
that people would be hooked by good
pricing of beginning and then gradually
hurt by increasing prices for that for
the the materials offered by google in
the registry well you can see similar
types of situations possibly with
insurers they bait and switch they say
oh here's a really cheap insurance
policy then you get sick you try to
claim all you got a pre-existing
condition oh you didn't tell us about
that hangnail you didn't tell us about
that whatever now there's ways in which
you have that same cocaine pricing
that worried about addiction or just
somehow being baited and switched in
health care we also have to worry about
insurers who avoid covering the sick hey
that's a worry about ensures that's a
that's a business practice they can
engage in especially because about
twenty percent of the people lead to
sixty-five to seventy percent of the
cost if you can avoid that twenty
percent you're doing very well as and
ensure the same type of worry comes up
with this type of access to information
with the middle man wants tiered access
schemes who may not care about reaching
the people who really can't pay very
much they want they may want to just
reach that twenty percent that can pay a
lot and the social value the social
issues raised by whether the book
registry and Google decide on a
high-margin low volume model okay which
is like to sell $100 licenses to 10
people or a low-margin high volume mark
model which is sell 100 licenses at a
dollar apiece that's huge but the
settlement doesn't give us any guidance
as to which direction they're going to
go there and in fact to be look at the
fear of transaction costs you'd pick to
license to 10 people at ten dollars at a
hundred dollars apiece rather than a
hundred at one dell or a thousand at one
dollar piece okay you'd rather license
to the smaller group than to the larger
one by and large under theories of
transaction costs so I think given there
are all these temptations of the
middleman of Google in the registry that
are really I think structurally similar
to the same types of problems that we've
seen in insurance companies we should be
happy because we have precedence in the
health industry for dealing with exactly
these types of troubling insurer
practices okay one of them was and the
best was the public alternative of
Medicare we learned by the 1960s that
were there were certain sorts of people
that would just systematically be left
out and I think that in the say by the
same logic we need to think seriously
about a digital deposit requirement may
be going back in time which may cause
some sort of takings issues we'll have
to address that but definitely going
forward in time such that there will be
a public alternative a public depository
that will be able to have exactly the
same access to a substrate of materials
that Google does I also think that
there's interesting antitrust literature
and theory on a logical calling this an
essential facility now if you want
competition in the search market you
essentially have to allow future search
engines future book order
their book search engines Ted access to
basically the large this large body of
data if you don't basically they're not
going to have nearly as much data and
information in order to compete in the
technology of search and of finding and
of ordering the other point I want to
make is that I think there are good
reasons to give to have mandatory
disclosure of the ranking systems used
in order to order the books on google
book search okay I don't think that it
would be a good thing for us to just
have no idea how the books are ordered
when we search for something on Google
book search but if we follow the example
of what happens on the search engine no
one knows how that's done and I think
and the search engine there's good
reasons for secrecy people worry about
gaming they say if Google said this is
how we rank the lab how we rank web
sites on the web everyone would game the
system okay it would be just spammed
entirely and we couldn't have order on
the web much harder to see the spamming
rationale in book search so I think
there is a rationale for mandatory
disclosure and again we have an example
of that and remember my example of how
insurers ranked doctors with smiley
faces okay and with all sorts of other
sort of simple ways of saying this is a
good doctor this is a bad doctor doctors
complained when they found out that they
were being ranked essentially not
according to their quality but to how
much they cost the insurer okay they
organized about that they got the New
York Attorney General to complain New
York Attorney General imposed a new
regime on them and said you have to
disclose how you rank the doctors higher
rate them I think similar transparency
must be demanded of a google book search
settlement once the force of the state
comes behind that as it will in the
approval of a settlement if it's proved
finally I'll say that you know Medicare
really is a model for me I think it for
this sort of alternative to google book
search which i think is maybe something
the Brewster is ultimately to be a huge
part of you know that that sort of
database and that that expertise and
knowledge and I think furthermore if we
think about compulsory licensing there
that could be exactly parallel to the
way in which the Medicare Payment
Advisory Committee is a price maker okay
it's a price maker in many areas of
Medicine by the same token we could see
this type of thing being done by a
compulsory licensing for access to works
in this government alternative so I
think our alternatives and our choices
are quite stark we could you know I know
it's a little washed out but this is a
dollar within Google
trust on its and we can simply trust in
market forces in these sort of
proprietary blackbox algorithms which
have admittedly done a lot to order the
web or we can try to balance a public
and a private option this by the way is
the key to contort contemporary health
reform debate you will be hearing huge
amounts over the next few months for
whether we'll have a public option or
not if we have a public option I think
health reform of work if we don't I
don't think it can but at least we have
a public option and Medicare it's a
wonderful example for us because it
proves that public and private can
coexist and so too can a public and a
Google run option of digitized books
thank you
thank you it's wonderful to be here
thank you in the nice very nice
perspective this has been actually
thrilling it's sort of like ted talk but
all about my subject this has been just
a a fabulous day I thought I'd ground
this a little bit with what's showing a
particular work that is sort of one of
the ones that we're talking about in the
whole google problem and it's a book
it's called libraries of the future by
Lickliter and it was referenced in
something going and saying well
Lickliter went and said that everything
was going to be digitized by the year
2000 and I was like one that's a God of
computer science but I hadn't read this
and so I went and try to find it and I
couldn't find it anywhere on the net
actually there was a copy was in the
internet archive but anyway and but I
couldn't really find a reasonable copy
of it and it was published in nineteen
sixty-five commissioned by a non-profit
published by MIT press about the library
of the future and if you look at this
book and sort of who who did it I don't
know if you can see that the the people
that are on that are on your are just
the gods of the time going and try to
contemplate what the library of the
future might look like so I went out and
I said well one of the libraries that
scanning books probably has this I
should probably introduce myself let me
just a smoke I'm brewster kahle I work
at the Internet Archive we're archiving
a lot of web pages but we're also
archiving and digitizing a lot of books
we digitize a thousand books a day we're
in 18 locations we're digitizing books
at the library of congress on moss we're
in five countries it's moving it's the
public sphere we have 1.2 million books
that are on the internet available for
free downloading for doing anything you
want no Google restrictions no lawyers
no nothing go for it and it's 1.2
million google says they have seven
million um I don't know what they really
have everything so secret with them but
anyway they say in court filings they
have seven million books 1.2 million and
we'll be at about two million by around
the end of the year and if you count in
what Denise Covey's project in India and
China
they've all told Don about 2 million
books so that's about 4 million books by
the end of the year that's in the public
sphere there is an alternative it's
really going on in a very big way you
wouldn't notice it from the press but we
don't employ as many lawyers PR firms
and the like anyway so that that's
that's who I am so I was able to go to
the University of Toronto's website a
library website look up this book and
find out that it was in there their
library so I asked to have it scanned um
and so it's here it is from the
University of Toronto is the book and
it's it's due back on april eighth two
thousand nine if you can see that anyway
so this is this particular book but it's
quite out of print it's available for
one hundred and thirty dollars if you go
and there's two copies available on on
some of the used martes that you can go
and see so it's very very out of print
but I really wanted to be able to see
this so on my own accord I when's that
I'll take the risk and ask it to be
digitized and we and we did a internet
archive when requested from the
University of Toronto scanned it put it
up and all sorts of things sort of
clicked into hooking it offline and this
took it offline offline offline offline
offline on because it was published in
nineteen sixty-five so also it's
automatic thread scope way can't have it
um anyway so I over road all of those
over road those right because I run the
place and so I and I wrote to Ellen of
foreign who runs is the administrative
head of MIT press and said hi Ellen um I
hope you don't mind I scan this book
because it's kind of a message to the
future in them and you know we are the
future this is what it was before and
she said okay well oh um you know good
to see you Brewster um uh you know yeah
why don't you keep keep keep it up i'll
do some research on it and i'll get back
to you tomorrow and then the next morn
out to be really hard i'm trying to
figure this out don't worry don't worry
we'll get back to you tomorrow and this
is going on for several day it takes
days of Labor to try to figure out
what's going on with these things and
this happens to be a book that is for us
so this size give you
sort of an idea of the problem oh it's
something i just did earlier i just went
and searched it for copyright to see if
in 1965 that they thought that was going
to be a problem the only occurrence of
copyright was on the copyright page
saying it's copyrighted to MIT right so
what happened so the other lesson of
this is something was orally wrong such
that we have to have this meeting in a
law school with you know with lots of
expensive people here um to talk about
the copyright stuff and it's the
copyright system went bizarrely wrong
since then okay so another piece of
contacts the M today's New York Times
it's still printed that's great um okay
so uh Miguel health on the front page as
a as a front page article says some
raise some raise alarms as Google
resurrects out of print books the lead
in the in the third paragraph said but
but a growing chorus is complaining that
a far-reaching settlement of a suit
brought against Google by publishers and
authors is about to grant the company
too much power over orphan works that's
the thing that's going on is orphan
works it's these works and there are
millions of them and in that context
that there is now a growing chorus it is
an issue and it's not everybody's not
singing Kumbaya on this particular one
and all given kind of an idea a court in
the Southern District of New York so
this is a different perspective on this
particular agreement will soon decide
whether it approve a proposed settlement
in a landmark case that could determine
our digital future the settlement is a
result of lawsuits filed a 19 in 2005
against Google by groups representing
authors and publishers claiming the
Google's book scanning project violated
copyright when google announced the
scanning project in december of 2004 the
company said its goal was simple yet
far-reaching like the web search engine
which points people to websites google's
book search product would help people
find information in books and in turn
direct them to volumes and libraries and
bookstores indeed the project seemed
perfectly
in keeping with the guiding principles
of the web itself which assumes a quid
quo pro between search engines and
websites that is sites allow themselves
be copied and indexed as long as search
engines like Google's lead people back
to the original site but as we learned
last October when the proposed
settlement was announced Google's
ambitions are far larger it turns out
google's search term google search tool
has become a digital book store a
settlement outlines business models for
creating and selling electronic editions
of books selling subscriptions to
google's new exclusive library whereas
the original lawsuit would have helped
us to find fair use in the digital age
the settlement has given us something
very different it's a new and unsettling
form of media consolidation if the
settlement is approved the outcome will
be not one but two court sanctioned
monopolies first Google will be the only
organization with the explicit license
to scan and sell access to in copyright
but out of print books which makes up
the vast majority of the books published
in the 20th century no other provider of
digital books will enjoy the same legal
protection the settlement also creates a
new entity called the books rights
registry which in conjunction with
google will set prices for all
commercial terms associated with those
digital books broad access is the great
promise of the digital age but given
control over such access to one company
no matter how clever or popular is a
danger to principles we hold dear free
speech open access to knowledge and
universal education through history
these principles have been realized in
the name
libraries publishers and our legal
system there are alternatives to
Google's approach separate from the
Google effort hundreds of libraries
publishers and technology firms are
already digitizing books with the goal
of creating an open freely accessible
system for people to discover for people
to borrow for people to purchase and for
people to read millions of books it's
not that expensive for the cost of 60
miles of highway if you use that as a
unit of money 60 miles of highway we can
have a 10 million book digital library
available to a generation growing
reading up growing up reading on screens
our job is to put the best works of
humankind within the reach of that
generation through a simple search on
the internet a student searching the
life of jf kennedy could be able to find
many books from many libraries and many
booksellers not be limited to one
private library whose books are
available for a fee controlled by a
corporation that can dictate what we can
read and what we're not allowed to read
we've wrestled with high tech monopolies
in the past IBM AT&T and most recently
Microsoft the lesson we learn was at
such strongholds restrict innovation and
competition in those cases it was the
courts that stepped in to address those
inequities now we have a proposal from
monopolies to be created by the courts
the court should not approve this
settlement monopolies will hinder not
help us achieve a rich and democratic
digital future laws and the free market
can support many innovative open
approaches to lending and selling books
for example we need legislation to
address works that are caught and
copyright limbo it's just dumb and we
need to stop these monopolies from
forming so that we can create vibrant
publishing environments we're very close
to having universal access to all
knowledge let's not stumble now
to repair my gross malfeasance by not
having PowerPoint slides i'm going to
show you show you two to try to give a
visual idea of what i think it's going
on now and the alternative that's being
proposed because often there are people
that are going and saying there is no
alternative we have to roll over finally
somebody's going to deliver us from our
in competence that's I don't think the
right thing that's going on at the
moment I'll give you a couple of
suggestions there's this diagram which
basically has the feeding into the two
large book databases that are going on
right now one is it google one is at
amazon i mean if you show this to
publishers or authors it one of our
section of this thing or the other will
cause them to wince that this future
which is what basically being built with
this settlement is a very few duopoly
kind of structure maybe there'll be a
third maybe Apple because they'll
control a device as well might spring
into this in some interesting way but
that's sort of the future I I grew up
helping try to build the internet in the
world wide web and I think that we can
do something quite a bit better and this
is what's going on with a bunch of
publishers authors and libraries it's
the idea of having open standards rather
than central organizations dictate how
readers machines reading devices can go
find what you might want out of search
engines did you notice there was a
plural on that search engines search
engines to be able to find lists of
where books that you might want to read
our what the terms are whether available
for borrowing or for buying and then
directly connect from the device to book
servers that are run by those libraries
and publishers
Frank or booksellers this is how the
world currently works if you just take
out the electronics this is kind of how
how the world currently works and there
are people that are interested in trying
to build this and we are building this
the google settlement as kind of an
end-run it's sort of a legislative trick
put forward in a class action suit that
sets up a monopoly that basically makes
it so that this will be much more
difficult to do so this is just to give
you kind of an idea of this and after
this though if there are any librarians
that would like to get together to talk
about how if you might want to be
involved in this please let me know I
thank you very much
this is your chance we put them to sleep
no hi the question for Brewster um I was
just wondering if you could go into a
little bit more detail and not how how
you see the current project you're
working on getting from this second
slide and cutting through this this
tangle of Rights with all of these
individual publishers and all these
individual authors to get towards a
workable assisted google has helped a
whole lot towards making this come about
and make this successful because they
are a frightening um entry into a world
that was relatively stayed so there's a
couple of things one you have to get the
publishers to come to the table to do
this and what's very difficult in a
distributed environment is doing digital
rights management that you know closes
every analog hole right that so the to
be able to have a distributed system
like this it helps a great deal if
people will sort of relax their
requirements for digital rights
management for purchased materials and
because of the the track record of what
happened with the music guys when they
basically sold their souls to Apple to
get for the carrot of digital rights
management they lost their industry
because there was one company that
controlled the distribution and the
pricing of their work and if somebody
does that you don't have a company you
have a division so they saw what
happened on there and what will happen
with the music guys as they started
selling mp3s but probably too late but
they started selling non-protected
things and selling them for real like
you know the old honest-to-god selling
things um and the music guys going
before Google's being so threatening the
conversations we're having with with
publishers are very very productive so
this is um so they're coming forward to
get the libraries on board the key thing
is that we can loan out of print works
and that's what it is libraries do is
loan works now I go and say restricted
out of print works because it's one
lot less contentious and it's a good
place to start we want to have
publishers continue to make things
accessible and flourish and this might
offer reason to believe that we might
have publishing as a distributed
industry going into the future and not
have it go into an elsevier or a
LexisNexis mode which is sort of you
know crushed down to one or two players
so libraries loaning out of print works
basically the 20th century and um
relaxing somewhat the digital rights
management screw-down they'll still be
some digital rights management but not
as much and Google has helped I'd
suggest on the publisher side and the
light it's up to the libraries to start
to step forward as we are in the loaning
area I've seen Frank and Jeff make notes
is that because you have comments you'd
like to add to this discussion
well I think the questioner and Brewster
and I actually agree on quite a lot
which is first that it whatever models
there are should not be exclusive and
second there is a thorny problem in how
you get the rights to these books so
Brewster referred to 10 million books
potentially right now that one point to
22 million I don't know if those are in
copywriter are not in copyright but the
question is how do you get rights to the
10 million books it's not just
publishers but authors have rights in
those books and authors positions are at
a minimum if we haven't granted the
publisher the electronic rights and
their electronic rights being exploited
here those are rights that the authors
control and in several cases indeed many
many cases the rights would have
completely reverted to the authors so
the publishers would have no rights to
give up I'm and in many cases of those
10 million books these books that
booster described as in copyright limbo
it's not so easy to find the publisher
the publisher isn't coming to the table
because the publishers out of business
or the rights have been transferred in
some way so the hard question that we've
all been grappling with is how do you
get the rights if you want to be in the
business that Brewster would like to be
in I think with respect to lending books
I'm not quite sure how that would work
but there isn't a digital first sale
doctrine so if one was copying a book
and lending the book out I'm not sure
whether or not you're getting rights
permission from the publishers or not
the authors to do that the libraries I
guess copyright owners would take the
position that the libraries don't have
the rights to authorize distribution
through lending but i think the rights
problem is the problem that Brewster is
is trying to focus on and I think it's
right for the questioner to raise it
maybe we could just say a little bit
about exclusivity that I was in another
one of these panels with one of the
people from the Publishers Association
said it let me read you there's one
sentence from this 440 page document
says look it says it's non-exclusive and
Fred fine woman from eff took them to
task I'm no lawyer but let me see if I
can make it through this the issue is
around the orphan works it's the things
that are not commercially viable the
things that didn't somebody didn't come
forward and put into the registry which
is going to be the vast majority of all
books that are out of print it's any
time that we've ever tried to get people
to sign up for anything you get a very
very low acceptance rate so it's all the
rest that's the issue it's the orphans
and as I understand it under a class
action on Google is the only one that is
allowed to it's the only one that has
explicit legal permission to scan and
sell those works if we wanted to start
doing those works of a nother author or
authors guild or ibooks rights registry
that suddenly has is flush with money
because of a very large settlement on
might come after us and say you don't
have the right to do that we might think
we do might be worth that the whole
issue but it we do not have legal
protection under this settlement in this
area Google and Google alone does
yes go ahead and then then we'll
continue this well just a comment and a
kind of question I suppose the the
common to Bruce respond as I suppose if
Microsoft really wanted to we could
start scanning have a quick litigation
and then a settlement similar to the the
settlement of Google I mean that would
be a mechanism to get to the same point
if Microsoft were willing to start the
scanning subject itself no litigation
try to get to try to get a class action
going young witch which you know
actually is not that far-fetched I mean
it would just do what if it saw that
there was money to be made it probably
would it knows how to do it it would
just do exactly what Google did but but
turning it to Frank's point about about
this the healthcare analogy what I'm
wondering is Twitter extent with the
you're talking about this the Medicare
component to what extent would the
public access service arguably fit or
address some of those Medicare type
concerns but then also building on the
Medicare or analogy as you know Medicare
is kind of expensive and wouldn't you
know that whole approach end up being
incredibly expensive sure I mean I think
just to respond to the last point first
I think that Terry Fisher's book
promises to keep is really wonderful in
terms of contextualizing list I mean we
had Jonathan's a tray and talk about the
lost shopping cart market being more
valuable than lead I thourough and I
think that fishers work points out that
at a cost as of two thousand four of six
dollars per month for all 34 million
broadband subscribers at that time that
would amount to the entire revenues of
the music and movie industry so you know
if you could have brokered that deal and
somehow set up an ASCAP that would have
done that you could have basically
bought them off if they were willing to
be bought off at that level and Japan
which has experience with this type of
thing in an ipod tax and other things as
you know found some success with that so
I think that although there are articles
criticizing the Japanese approach I
think in terms of the larger Medicare
issue one of the things that I think is
problematic about our comparison
Republican
sectors is that it's often unfair
because what the public sector does has
to be transparent has to be open and so
immediately when there's an abuse you
know we know how much Larry summer was
made from de shaw last year or whatever
and as to speak of today's headline a
lot of weapons of the private sector can
be protected by the veil of trade
secrecy and I think that my main
argument here is when I compare the
pricing practices of say private
insurers with a messy and sloppy but at
least transparent Medicare approach I
think there is at least a role to have
that messy and sloppy troj to be a
counterbalance and perhaps even a
baseline for the private approach
any other questions or comments audience
yes I am getting kind of an uneasy
feeling in the Google settlement I'd
like the panel to discuss this in light
of how libraries are coming out given
the fact that immense amounts of capital
investment in buying books and building
buildings in staff over decades of
decades how does that balance out with
what libraries are getting out of the
settlement I'd like some comments on
that well I I'll start I think from I
don't represent libraries but obviously
a number of libraries have entered into
digitization agreements with Google
Google is obviously picking up the costs
of scanning the books in those libraries
collections and the libraries are
getting back these library digital
copies and there's a whole section of
the settlement agreement that discusses
the uses that can be made of those
library digital copies I think I verted
to some of them in my presentation
everything from making replacement
copies to providing access to the
visually impaired to sort of certain
classroom uses to integrating the
library digital copies into the
library's electronic finding tools so
that you get snippets from from the book
so this morning when we saw the a
library two point O you'd actually get
little snippets from the books on global
warming if those books had been scanned
and so I think there's a fair amount in
there for libraries that are fully
participating libraries and are getting
library digital copies back it might get
done also oh oh I just a very quick boys
I really would one sort of requests or
challenge or hope that I would I would
have for the audience's that I think
that what's happening with Google in
terms of its organization is it is an
amazing algorithm but it's it's
and I think that one way for librarians
to sort of maintain and to build on that
role and all the investment librarians
have done in terms of picking books and
using their expertise and use the
organizational abilities is to make the
case that they need to be a vital part
of this public option of helping you
know in something like the open
directory project or otherwise
organizing the web and helping to
organize knowledge I think that Google
does many things wonderfully but there's
also a role for librarians to keep using
that expertise in the digital context
let me try to give some numbers as to
sort of what's what's really going on in
terms of money so in terms of how did
they get these deals I think Dan Daniel
Greenstein of University of California I
think had at best Google is expert at
exploiting the balkanization of the of
the libraries especially the university
libraries the library see themselves as
competing with each other and Google is
very good at separating them off they'd
in general everything is guarded with
non-disclosures there was no basically
way for these organizations which is
usually appear oriented group there's a
there's a lot of discussion they may
compete but they talk back and forth
Google stopped all of that conversation
between these organizations and then
exploited the balkanization and got them
on board then there's the
bait-and-switch of this settlement
requires these libraries to then
actually change and put under more
restrictions in the original signed up
for for the books that were digitized a
while ago but they're still there's are
already engaged so this is some of the
mechanics that they used but let's go
over how much it costs so the to scan a
book the Internet Archive scans books at
ten cents a page and these are we think
very beautiful QA beautiful works and it
so it's about thirty dollars a book 300
page book on cost there four times ten
cents thirty dollars a book as best I
can tell from talking with some folks in
and around the google project it's much
less than
$10 a book probably more like five
dollars a book because they're very good
at going very fast and they kind of say
well we'll fix it later let's use the
number of five dollars a book for the
google project they say in their court
filings that they've done seven million
books seven million books at five
dollars each is 35 million dollars for
all of the scanning that they have said
in this court filing that they do to
give a little bit of perspective and
what's yields library budget in a year
depends on what you count cork or
collections budget is around 18 to 19
million 18 to 19 million for the core
collection on the total library system
in the United States just take the
United States budget it's 12 billion
dollars a year 12 billion dollars a year
spent every year on our libraries most
of it goes to staff and facilities but
about 30 to 20 five to thirty three
percent of that as best I can tell by
doing them informal poll goes to
publishers products and it's going up
over time it's mostly going to these
database vendors so three to four
billion dollars a year is being spent by
libraries published buying things from
publishers out of a 12 billion dollar a
year industry so we're talking about
over a course of several years Google
having spent an estimated everything
secret there of 35 million dollars if
you were to go and build a 10 million
book library which a 10 million book
library is that the class of Harvard New
York public not quite at the Library of
Congress and sort of Princeton Yale ish
as I understand it so about 10 million
book library if you were to do at the
highest grade quality this thirty
dollars a book um then we'd get a 300
million dollar project it would probably
by the time you'd actually spend that
much money would probably be much more
efficient so it'd be quite a bit less
the hundred million to 300 million for a
high quality available to all of a
collection that would basically be the
works of humankind is kind of the right
size so we're talking a couple percent
of one year's budget that we spend on
libraries is what it is we're doing a
Faustian bargain for and it ain't work I
almost feel the need to push back a
little bit at some of this Kenny Cruz
told us that he stopped using the word
balance with respect to copyright so I'm
going to try to use it with respect to
library purchasing collections services
all of those other things no library can
begin to meet all the needs of all of
its users I mean you know it's that
they're just legion when when we call
for budget requests the budget requests
are invariably twice what we will ever
be able to assign to anything and I
think that's a good thing but it also
means that we have to think about how we
allocate resources we are you know even
in our own 18 19 million dollar way
quite user-driven we pay close attention
to student and faculty needs and
requests we try to fill them we try to
see you know what are the courses being
taught what are the research projects so
on and so forth I have to say that there
is something in me that cannot wait to
get my hands on those seven million
books for our campus community I hope
that there will pray and hope and
believe that there's going to be a
chance for the library community to sit
at one of the negotiating tables and
that's the table that works out whatever
the fees and licenses are particularly
consortium in some scaled up way so that
we will be able in addition to all the
resources that we're already bringing in
we can add this resource and I know that
sounds like heresy but I also know that
the second that this resource becomes
available anywhere probably a thousand
Yale users will line up put our doors
and say why don't we have access to it
so you know when we're thinking about
balancing that one of the things we have
to think about is users services their
research their courses their projects
what do they need and that's very much
driver in irons
tutions we try not to do any of that
without selling our souls we are very
careful about licenses we sign I mean we
you know we are well staffed in that
area maybe not well enough but there's
there's a very big part of me that hopes
that this can work and that the this
will also lead to other things that can
work that the Google settlement might
and I now more cautious but might become
a sort of template for other kinds of
arrangements and settlements on a large
scale so I I hope that's not too naive
but I think for many of the librarians
sitting here you know we hear our users
and Google that will content a lot of
these others are very very important for
them